[Music]
last summer I was visiting family in
Singapore when I got a text message we
respond to Miami love yesterday thanks
not knowing the number I respond with
the usual sorry who is this
Adam s comes response thanks for not
realizing thanks for not realizing
that's obnoxious but whatever I'm gonna
be polite here so I respond with sorry
what's your full name I don't see any
emails from you to which he responds
Adam losing patience Solar Adam losing
patience Solar are you serious like who
are you I'm being patient with you your
first strike was thanks for not
realizing but this one's really pushing
it where are your manners so I pulled my
phone I frustrated and be like let me
teach you how to spell losing cuz you
clearly didn't go to primary school
instead I paused and I showed the text
message to my younger brother who read
it and said wait a minute
I think dad works for an atom solar and
then it dawned on me I was boring my dad
SIM card in Singapore so I must have
been texting his coworkers so I run to
dad is from the phone be like dad I
think I'm talking to your to your
friends there and he reads the
conversation looks up and says poke it
I'm glad you're not the angry puppy that
used to be otherwise today I'd be
looking for a new job this experience
first introduced me to the notion that
emotional intelligence is extremely
important in the business workplace
it can literally save your job and turns
out there's a lot of data to support
this Daniel Goleman who writes about
this in the Harvard Business Review
arrives at this conclusion
he says emotional intelligence matters
more and more to higher up you get in a
company in fact the difference between a
star performer and an average performer
is 90% attributable to emotional
intelligence consider the following two
examples where a lack of emotional
intelligence was quite harmful uber CEO
Travis kalanick
got in a fight with an uber driver on
video the uber driver is seen telling
cowl neck that he lost ninety seven
thousand dollars and went bankrupt
because rubra changed his policies and
reduced fares cowl-neck then yells back
saying some people don't like to take
responsibility for their own [ __ ] they
blame everything on somebody else this
outburst cost kalmyk personally two
hundred thousand dollars and eventually
contributed to him losing his job or
consider Elon Musk
when British diver Vernon Unsworth
publicly criticized Elon Musk's ideas on
Twitter musk lashed back calling him a
pedophile and a child rapist this led to
a prolonged media crisis and a lawsuit
my point is that I should be the CEO of
Tesla and uber
but in all seriousness as we progress in
our careers we'll be faced by situations
and people that test our patience more
and more frequently and in those
situations the cost of not handling that
with poise will also increase so it's of
paramount importance that we work on our
emotional intelligence before we go out
and change the world so you're probably
wondering now how do I do this well
there's two important parts of the brain
that need to be trained sequentially the
first is the neocortex the neocortex
handles logic so if you want to learn
Excel you read a book and now you know
how to use Excel it learns quickly the
limbic system handles emotions this
one's a little slower to teach something
to the limbic system we need consistency
or practice over a long time so how
about we take the first step together
let's train our neocortex and let's take
the example of anger so first our aim
here is to convince the neocortex that
in some situations anger is
counterproductive so in the case of the
text messages when I get angry
I'm excreting chemicals in my body that
are literally poisoning my system in
other words I'm drinking the poison and
I'm hoping that the guy on the other
side of the text message gets hurt so
what does the neocortex say to this
illogical in the case of Travis kalanick
we need to understand that anger is not
helping him drive towards objective if
anything is pushing him further away not
only did he fail to convince the uber
driver of his side of the argument he
also lost a lot of money and eventually
his job so what is the neocortex side of
this again illogical and in the case of
Elon Musk we need to understand that if
he lets every hater online get him
bothered then boy is he gonna live a
terrible life in this case he may not
have lost his job but he will definitely
lose his peace of mind every time a
bully picks up a phone and fires off a
tweet so hopefully by now your neocortex
is convinced that
some situations anger is
counterproductive now comes the hard
part the limbic system because you can
convince your neocortex or something but
your limbic system will say I'm still
angry
I still have anger now I've been working
on this for a while like you remember my
dad said as an angry child and I found
the pro methodology to work really well
for me the peon Pro stands for pause
pausing in a difficult situation gives
you time to act instead of reacting so
when I go to text message I was able to
pause and gather more information and
then act as opposed to reacting with an
equally sassing message the RN Pro
stands for a reframe when uber CEO
Travis kalanick heard those words he
took that as a personal affront to him
instead he could have reframed those
words as product feedback coming from a
very important company constituents the
drivers had he done that he could have
probably avoided the 2019 uber strike
that happened right before the IPO and
the OM Pro stands for own own your
emotions and in my opinion the most
important one currently we blame the
external circumstances for internal
emotions so we're constantly trying to
fix the external world to fix our
internal world but the reality is that
our influence on the external world is
heavily limited so Owen means to go from
an external locus of control for
emotions to an internal locus of control
for emotions so Elon Musk did not get
angry because somewhere some person
hated on him on Twitter he got angry
because internally he was attached to
the idea that no one should criticize
him publicly and by changing that
expectation he can change his emotional
state
so how about we handle this situation
like a pro
and pause reframe maybe a spilling juice
oliver myself makes this more
entertaining for you and there'll be
more views and own
I'm not feeling what I'm feeling right
now because that's flow juice over
myself it's because I had an expectation
internally that this talk go flawlessly
so my point is that when in these
situations anger is not the only thing
that can be worked on with Pro you can
also do this with disappointment with
hatred with sadness any other emotion so
I hope that you walk out of this room
and next time you're faced with a
challenging situation you evaluate the
merit of the emotional reaction and then
you pause you reframe and you own thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]